Matthew Perry had the type of success
that most can only dream of but it also
came with a cast from numerous
hospitalizations to the many years he
spent battling his addiction Perry's
personal life was far from perfect
Matthew Perry was raised in Ottawa
Canada and his parents were significant
figures his father John Bennett Perry
was an American actor best recognized
for minor roles in films like the legend
of the Lone Ranger meanwhile Perry's
mother Susan Marie Morrison was a former
Beauty Queen who served as press
secretary to the country's prime
minister they're both people that take
over a room you know when they come in
unfortunately the pair separated before
their son reached his first birthday
Perry's mother would find a new partner
and celebrated dine correspondant Keith
Morrison however the young performer
admitted that he didn't see much of them
while he was growing up in his 2022
Memoir friends lovers and the big
terrible thing Perry wrote I spent a
great deal of time alone even more
tragically when it came to seeing his
father Perry wrote I saw his face more
often on TV or in magazines than I did
in reality Perry also admitted that he
started misbehaving at an early age by
the age of 10 he was smoking and
stealing money meanwhile Perry admitted
to having his first taste of alcohol at
14 it make him as a surprise that before
Perry became an actor he had his sight
set on a tennis career the actor first
hit the court when he was 4 years old
training nearly 10 hours a day by age 13
He ranked among the best for juniors in
his home country of Canada however when
Perry moved in with his father in
California the reality of a sports
career seemed much more daunting he
explained in a 2012 interview with Men's
Health I was a very good tennis player
in Ottawa Canada nationally ranked when
I was like 13 then I moved to Los
Angeles when I was 15 and everyone in La
just killed me I was pretty great in
Canada not so much in Los Angeles
thankfully the young Star had a backup
plan he told Men's Health I realized I
wouldn't be playing tennis for a living
so I went for acting are tennis and
acting alike I don't know they're both
very mental games while his career
ultimately went in a different direction
tennis remained a passion for the actor
as his last public appearance was
reportedly at the 2023 French Open in
Paris Matthew Perry openly expressed
that the most significant demon of his
life was his addiction struggles his
Memoirs released just one year before
his passing illuminated many of the
challenges that the actor faced he
described himself as an alcoholic since
he first started drinking as a teenager
how however his addictions overtook his
life after he was prescribed to
painkillers following a jet ski accident
in 1997 resulting in his first stay at a
rehabilitation Clinic the same year by
2000 Perry shrinking led to him being
hospitalized with pancreatitis that same
year he crashed his portion to the steps
of his Hollywood home in a 2002
interview with people the actor
describes the amount of drugs and
alcohol was consuming at the time he
told the outlet that it ingests as many
as 55 vicadin a day while drinking
drinking upwards of a quarter vodka well
I had to wake up
and realize that I needed to get 55 of
them or I was going to be really sick in
a separate 2022 interview with people
Perry admitted I didn't know how to stop
if the police came over to my house and
said if you drink tonight we're going to
take you to jail I'd stop packing I
couldn't stop because the disease and
the addiction is Progressive so it gets
worse and worse as you grow older
Matthew Perry's addiction problems
ultimately collided with his acting
career Perry landed the role of Chan Le
Bing when he was 24 years old just as
his addiction was truly beginning to
take the Reigns he told people I could
handle it kind of but by the time I was
34 I was really entrenched in a lot of
trouble while appearing on BBC Radio 2
in 2016 he was questioned on his least
favorite episode from friends and he
candidly replied I think the answer is I
don't remember 3 years of it he went on
to admit that season 3 to season 6 were
blurred in his Memories the actor
struggled to look back at his time on
the Beloved sitcom as it was equally one
of the most challenging eras of his life
he told Tom power in an interview I
can't watch the show because I was
brutally thin and being beaten down so
badly by the disease I could tell season
by season by how I looked and I don't
think anybody else can but I certainly
could as Perry struggles with addiction
intensified he worried about
disappointing his co-stars the actor
said in an ABC news interview I made a
rule that I would never drink or take
anything at work but I would show up
blindly hung over I thought I was hiding
it so well unfortunately the five other
prominent friends were each affected by
Perry struggles at one point or another
Lisa cudro told the New York Times when
Matthew was sick it was not fun we would
just hopelessly standing on the
sidelines he were hurting a lot
meanwhile Matt LeBlanc also admitted to
people that he tried to help his
onscreen roommate But ultimately felt
like there was little he could do
however it was Jennifer Aniston whom
Perry praised in his ABC interview
saying but but she was the one that
reached out the most you know I'm really
grateful to her for that Perry conceded
that he would not have made it through
10 seasons without his castmates writing
in his Memoir they were patient it's
like penguins penguins in nature when
one is sick or when one is very injured
the other penguin surround it and prop
it up they walk around it until that
penguin can walk on its own that's kind
of what the cast did for me Perry had a
lifelong grudge match with his addiction
one of his biggest realizations came
when he put the numbers down for how
much he has invested into getting clean
he told the New York Times I've probably
spent $9 million or something trying to
get sober it's still a day-to-day
process of getting better in addition to
the time and effort he put into sobriety
Perry also did his part to give back in
2013 he opened the doors of his Malibu
Beach House transitioning it into a
dedicated sober living facility for men
suffering from addiction is if somebody
comes up to me and says I can't stop
drinking can you help me I I can say yes
and follow up and do it the aply named
Perry house was eventually sold in 2015
because of the high operating costs of
living in Malibu however Perry continued
to take significant pride in being able
to help those who have suffered the same
hurdles as himself he told People
magazine when I die I'd like friends to
be listed behind helping people after
Decades of pushing his health to the
brink the substance huse caught up with
Matthew Perry in 2018 the actor suffered
a gastrointestinal perforation and
narrowly survived the traumatic event he
told people in 2022 the doctors told my
family that I had a 2% chance to live I
was put on a thing called an ECMO
machine which does all the breathing for
your heart and your lungs and that's
called a Hail Mary no one survives that
Perry revealed that the life-threatening
situation put him in a coma for 2 weeks
followed by a 5-month hospital stay
However the close call had lasting
implications on his life he had over a
dozen surgeries and carried a colostomy
bag for 9 months as a result of his
health complications he recalled my
therapist said the next time you think
about taking Oxycontin just think about
having a colostomy bag for the rest of
your life a little window opened and I
crawled through it and I no longer want
Oxycontin anymore undoubtedly Perry
counted His blessings and used his
second chance at life to complete his
Memoirs there were five people put on an
ECMO machine that night and the other
four died and I
survived many of the details of Matthew
Perry's life have only become available
thanks to the actor's 2022 Memoir
however though when the book was
published Perry received heavy backlash
from fans and celebrities alike for
taking punches at one of Hollywood's
most beloved figures Keanu Reeves Perry
wrote In the book why is it that the
original thinkers like River Phoenix and
Heath leged but Keanu Reeves still walks
Among Us by all accounts the friends
actor never professionally cross path
with the Matrix star making the name
drop more confusing in the wake of the
one-sided Feud many celebrities vocalize
the defense for ree Billy Baldwin said
in a post on X for formerly known as
Twitter in a world full of Matthew
Perry's via Keanu Reeves following the
negative reaction Perry was quick to
apologize the actor said in a statement
to deadline I'm actually a big fan of
Keanu I just chose a random name my
mistake I apologize I should have used
my own name instead throughout his life
Matthew Perry dated some of the biggest
actresses in Hollywood some of the
high-profile women that cross paths with
the actor included Julia Roberts and
Gwyneth paltro sadly despite rubbing
elbows to some of the most elite
Bachelor Perry Never held down a
committed relationship for long while
talking about his past romantic life
Perry wrote in his book I need love but
I don't trust it if I drop my game like
Chandler and show you who I really am
you might notice me but worse you might
notice me and might leave me and I can't
have that on one of his most
heartbreaking breakups he wrote I was
broken bent unlovable so instead of
facing the inevitable Agony of losing
her I broke up with the beautiful and
Brilliant Julia Roberts are you dating
this Matthew Perry guy I am dating this
Matthew Perry guy the friend star seemed
to have finally found love when he got
engaged to Molly Hertz in 2020 however
the pair called off the wedding a few
months later with Perry telling people
sometimes things just don't work out and
this is one of them with all the
tribulations that Matthew Perry faced
throughout his life the actor had
seemingly gotten himself back on a
healthy track while promoting his book
in 2022 he boasted a clean lifestyle in
his interview with people he even joked
I'm pretty healthy now I've got to not
go to the gym much more because I don't
want to only be able to play superheroes
but no I'm a pretty healthy guy right
now with the worst seemingly behind the
Beloved sitcom star it was extra
shocking when it was revealed on October
28th 2023 that Perry had died from an
apparent drowning in a hot tub Perry's
family wrote in a statement to people we
are heartbroken by the tragic loss of
our beloved Son and brother Matthew
brought so much Joy to the World both as
an actor and a friend additionally they
sent a message to Perry's fans across
the globe you all meant so much to him
and we appreciate the tremendous
outpouring of love if you or anyone you
know needs help with addiction issues
help is available visit the Substance
Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration website or contact Sam's
National helpl line that's 1 1800 662
help